So, good afternoon everyone. Thank you
so much for being here. I'm Miss
Bridget. Um, even though I'm going to be
presenting in English because of time, I
always want to start in Spanish to
reiterate um how much we value the
Spanish language that we are a bilingual
community and it's something important
to me and to our community. Um, so
families, whether this is your first
time at a meeting like this or you've
been to several, we're very grateful to
have you here. Thank you so much to our
district staff or superintendent who is
here with us to to spend this time
together. Um, a few announcements. So,
we do have refreshments in the back with
Mr. Juan. Thank you, Mr. Juan, who's
always available. Um, as you most know,
we have child care outside. If at any
point you need to leave, you're welcome
to exit around the sides or through the
back. We also have a restroom over to
this area.
uh three brief uh notes before we get
started today. So one is people might be
wondering why we are sitting like this.
Um an important part of a monastery
education is we have children of
multiple ages together but the respect
that we have for each other is equal
right and so this is my interpretation
of a circle because it's a lot of people
to put in one circle. Um and thankfully
Miss Sandra our wonderful admin
assistant helped me figure out what this
would look like. Miss Allison, our
librarian, helped figure out logistics.
So, thank you so much. Mr. Devon and it
helped us figure out how to get the
screen. So, we're grateful that this
gives a a place where we can see each
other. Um, we can hear each other. Um,
and we are all coming at a level playing
field, which is something important to
us. The second piece is a celebration.
So, we know that this is an incredibly
diverse community, right? We have
families and staff and students from
different countries, from different
states, who speak different languages,
who have different abilities and
disabilities. We have people from
different income backgrounds. And we
have people who are new to Monasuri,
people who have done Monasuri for
decades, people who chose the school for
Monasuri and people who lived in the
neighborhood and walked across the
street and are less maybe concerned
about what Monastery can do for them and
their family. That means that unlike
some of the communities who were able to
speak with one voice, that's going to be
harder for us, right? Because we are
coming to this with different pieces.
But what has always been true about our
community is this is a community that
cares deeply about children, who
believes in their child and their
child's needs, but doesn't speak for
their child over someone else's. And
we've been really mindful in this
process to think about an individual
child, our children, the children in
northeast Austin, the children in East
Austin, and the children in Austin
together. And I know that's something
that will continue today. The other
piece, as you know, I am an emotional
person um as many of us are when we talk
about to students about feelings. Um we
always talk about that no feeling is a
bad feeling, right? And any feeling you
have is a valid feeling. So if you came
today and you were feeling concerned or
frustrated or sad or angry, all of those
feelings are okay, right? Those are
welcome here. What matters when we talk
to kids about and adults sometimes too,
right? Is how we present those feelings.
And again, when you're talking about
your own children or your own
experience, it can be uh hard sometimes
to not pit your child against someone
else's child or to accidentally say
something that feels really hurtful to
someone else. So something we've done
really well again so far in these
difficult conversations to be thoughtful
about how we share those feelings so
that someone else who's hearing this in
the idea of their child feels safe and
welcome in our community. So I'm very
grateful and honored to be a part of
this conversation. Um at this point I'm
going to turn it over to Miss Ally. Oh,
we also go by first names who's going to
talk about norms for this afternoon.
>> Good afternoon everyone. Oo that's loud.
My name is Ally Gillard Duchi. I'm the
senior executive director of
communications community engagement. I'm
just going to review our agenda and the
purpose of this meeting as well as some
meeting norms that um principal Far
obviously teed off very nicely um before
I pass it over to our superintendent for
some remarks.
Um so for our agenda, um like I said,
I'm going to go over the meeting norms
and purpose. Um we will introduce some
of the folks and thank you so much.
Someone had emailed me asking who was
coming and we all had um name tags which
is delightful. Um then we're going to
provide y'all with an overview of the
proposed um changes that are campus
specific as well as we've marked them up
with anything that was different about
the latest release that you would have
received on Friday. Um then we're going
to respond to questions um received in
the comment card. So our team has poured
through all of those. We've looked for
themes. In some instances it might be a
question with a specific person's name.
In other instances it might be a
question that we heard multiple times.
So, we want to make sure we get to we
can kind of alternate between the
presubmitted questions and in-person
questions. The only thing that I'm going
to ask is that we speak in turn and um
because we are recording this meeting,
it's in English as well as their Spanish
interpretation and they I don't know
where they are, but they are recording
in Thank you. She's recording into a
microphone in Spanish so that we can
then share this meeting in English and
Spanish. So, if we call on you, please
wait to get the mic so that we can
capture the full experience for the
recording. Um, and then we'll talk about
next steps. So, I'm just going to
briefly go over the norms. Um, what
we're here for is building the future
together. We want to acknowledge the
challenges of our current situation
while focusing on ideas and solution
that will make our district stronger,
more equitable, and sustainable for
years to come. We want to honor we have
allocated about 90 minutes for this
meeting. Um, so when we do get around to
giving the mic out to folks, if you can
make an effort to keep your comment to
around a minute, that just makes sure
that we can maximize the number of folks
who get to speak. Um, we want to honor
the process, so staying on the agenda.
Um, honoring intent and impact. So,
we're probably going to disagree on some
ideas, but I hope the one thing that we
can agree on is the reason we are all
here is to focus on creating strong,
equitable schools for all Austin ISD
students. Um, we want to honor space and
voice. So that means if you do get the
mic one time and you have a follow-up,
we're happy to allow you to have a
follow-up, but we are going to try to
not get back to the same person until
everyone else who's had their hands
raised um gets an opportunity to speak.
Um we want to try to stay
solutionsoriented, so focusing on ideas,
solutions, and understanding. Um and we
want to embrace, we here are committing
to embracing transparency and empathy.
Um, we know these are difficult
conversations, but um, we're here to
provide compassion, um, clarity, and
honesty. And so that means if you ask a
question and you feel like we didn't
answer it very well or it felt like it
was sidestep, please feel free to ask a
follow-up. We want to make sure you
leave with your questions truly
answered.
And then just the purpose of the
meeting, kind of reiterating, um, we
want to make sure that we're responding
to some of those questions that came up
multiple times through the comment
cards. We want to make sure we all have
a shared understanding of what's
actually being proposed at this stage in
the process. And we as administration
want to gain insights that are going to
inform additional refinements that could
be folded into the draft um plan that we
ultimately ask our board to vote on on
November 20th.
And with that, I'm going to hand it over
to our superintendent. He's going to
share a little bit about the context of
the environment we're in, the why behind
this process before we get into the
comment cards and Q&A.
>> I've I've got one. I think you're
supposed to use this one. I don't know
why.
>> Okay.
So, I I love that this is Bridget's
interpretation of a circle. Uh
um no, this is fantastic. Thank you all
for being here. Uh I know these are
difficult conversations, difficult time.
Uh I want to make sure we're responsive
and create space. This is your time. Uh
I do think it's important uh before we
get going just to share with you how we
got here and why you know this plan is
the current draft plan. Again draft it
will refine there will be adjustments to
it.
Like things are really hard right now.
um just they're just really really hard
in Austin ISD
in public education
and I would say the board and I are
desperately trying to find a way to
stabilize this school system that we
love and ensure that every student gets
what they need
where they are. Um, which is why we are
talking about neighborhood schools and
and the importance of them. In Austin
ISD, we have lots of families that don't
believe that the school that they're
zoned to serves their family needs or
their student needs. And that's a
problem. Like that is a huge problem for
our school district if we are going to
be sustainable and support our students
in our way moving forward. And so when
we started this work, um there were a
lot of things that were the catalyst for
us just starting. Um the first was
recognizing that no one's going to come
save us when it comes to our budget
challenges. Uh the inefficiencies we
have in our system, the declining
enrollment, like no one's going to help
us. The second thing was these budget
challenges that we have, you know,
they're exacerbated by the declining
enrollment. But I also want to be really
clear. The changes in the federal
government have put immense pressure on
our system. Uh I don't often talk about
it because it's not talked about a whole
bunch. Uh but title two, title three,
and title four dollars which were
previously frozen this year then
released, they will be going away,
right? These are millions and millions
and millions of dollars that we use to
serve our students who have been
historically underserved. Like that's
the reality of it all. um many folks
within a vets team uh our multilingual
education team were impacted by these
decisions. And so each and every time
something happens to us, I have to try
to figure out a way to, you know, take
the body blow because that's what it is.
Figure out how to protect like who we
are as an organization and ensure that
we're viable to meet our students needs.
Like that's that's really a lot of what
we've been tackling. And then you add on
top of that what we want to do um as a
school system uh and who we are and what
we believe in. Right? The last two years
we had lots of conversations around what
we believe in and each of those things
had an impact on where we are now. About
18 months ago we had a real conversation
around you know planning time. We've had
conversations around essential areas.
We've had conversations around
protecting [clears throat] librarians.
protecting nurses. Like there are all
these things that we as a school
district have said we believe this is
what's necessary to support our whole
child and if we hold those things true
we have to acknowledge there's going to
be resources deployed in order to
support it right dollars
we also know that for us and I believe
this to the core of my being that we
begin and end in the unit of change are
our educators in the classrooms are like
when we were coming out of the pandemic
you know we had tons of vacancies
throughout the school system. We had
tons of vacancies within our principal
ships. And we have been like pulling
ourselves out of that moment in time.
And what made things even worse is that
you had change after change after change
within the leadership of Austin ISD.
And so as we move forward, what we had
to take on had to be significant enough
for us to be able to move the system and
evolve. The state accountability system
is not going away. It's not. I get asked
all the time, Matias challenged this.
Matias has challenged this. What we know
is that our commissioner has immense
authority. What is said goes and if
we're not responsive to it, no matter
how much we feel otherwise, we will be
put in a position where local control
could move away from us. And it and it
can happen and it can happen quickly if
you're not very responsive to it.
The other thing is when we look at
solutions or we look at plans long term,
we want to make sure that we are
identifying solutions that might not
otherwise exist because we brought
people together and we tackled many
things at one time. And so this plan
includes several elements. I'm going to
just quickly lay them out um so that
you're if you're understanding like
Matias like why did you consider this
and not this? you'll see how these
overarching objectives uh were
considered. First, we wanted to have
aligned feeder patterns everywhere in
ISTD. Um, you know, they're not perfect
because we are an organization that's
been around for 144 years. Maybe I
should move to this part of the circle.
And our boundaries were built out of our
>> Switch microphones. Switch microphones.
>> Switch microphones.
So, we've been built out of a series of
decisions and boundaries for over 144
years, right? And there were plans that
were made. There were there's
desegregation that occurred. There were
lots of things that informed how our
boundaries came to be. And right now,
what we know is that there are certain
experiences that students have in parts
of Austin where they have very clean
quote unquote cleaner patterns. And
there are parts of Austin, and you guess
where these are, where we don't have
clean theater patterns. So, what does
that mean? It means that you have middle
schools that are going to three, four,
and five high schools in some parts of
Austin. And then you have schools in
other parts of Austin, and guess where
they are, where one middle school goes
wholly into a high school. And so, if
we're ever going to address that, it has
to be a comprehensive change because
every high school boundary has to align
with every middle school boundary. and
those middle school boundaries have to
align with those elementary school
boundaries. So that was one big like
objective that we had in this um effort.
Two, we wanted to address our transfer
policies and our operating procedures
around them. We've got policies in place
that have been around for decades.
And the reality is that some of these
policies have brought into our school
system behaviors that I don't think
represent who we are now. And so if
we're going to be thoughtful about it,
we need to look at them and make
adjustments. And this plan attempts to
do that. The third thing, programmatic
alignment. And I'm going to include
monastery in this kind of bucket of
elements
of kind of the overall um plan, draft
plan. And it's that, you know, we in
Austin ISD and I I would say I certainly
believe that we want our students to
have access to programming in Austin ISD
that's unique to Austin, but I also want
to be really clear about what does
access mean. Uh, you know, access may
sound great, but if we're not providing
transportation or it's not located
geographically um to where anybody can
reasonably get to it, it's not
accessible.
uh when I think about the wall-to-wall
to language programs which is kind of a
big part of this aspect of the work you
know the intent uh originally um as it
was formed was to ensure that our
emerging bilingual students were the
center of the program and what we've
seen over time as a city has changed
that we're within the number of students
who are emerging bilingual has be begun
to decline and continues to decline. So
in order to provide access, we need to
move where those students are, right?
And then really think about how we
ensure that they stay in that community
and access these schools. The other
thing I'll say is reduction in overall
um I would say improvement in
efficiencies, reduction in overall cost.
This is the hardest one to talk about
because it it's hard to talk about
funding or dollars and cents because it
can seem so removed from the classroom.
It just seems so like like just sterile
and and not loving. But at the end of
the day, you know, everything we do
requires funding. Our compensation for
teachers, which represent and staff is
87% of our budget. The curriculum that
we acquire. Like we spend millions and
millions of dollars every single year on
our curriculum. And I can promise you
there are less expensive alternatives.
But I am certain that this community and
many communities around Austin would not
support that curriculum if I pursued it.
Though I could save $8 million.
And when we think about how we reduce
our overall kind of cost as a system, we
start with where are we misaligned?
And for us that represents number of
empty seats that we have in our school
system. It's one way to look at it. It's
not the only way to look at it, but it's
one way to look at it. And so as a
school system, you know, and y'all have
heard me say this before, perhaps, maybe
you haven't. You know, in 1996, we had
about 96 schools. It's kind of funny
that it matches up that way. Um, in
2025, you have 116 and you had roughly
the same student population at that time
as you do now. Now, there's a big
increase in between and then a decrease.
But just for context, like we've grown
with the city and as gentrification has
occurred, as families have been priced
out because of how costly it is to live
in Austin, families have moved, but our
buildings have stayed. So, in order for
us to tackle that, we have to think
about the whole and make adjustments as
part of that plan. And then lastly, and
I think this also considers why we're
here today um and talking about when
Monastery is just the reality of the
accountability system that we're in.
Like I have tell I tell people tell I'm
blue in the face like our schools are
doing incredible things and I actually
use win as an example often because
people will say well this school is not
performing this school's not performing
you know I'm like no but like our
schools are so much be more than a
letter grade they are and this is a
great example of of what that means when
but it's not known to everybody
especially when you're talking at a
5,000 10,000 even 20,000 foot level like
that connection doesn't always come
across but the reality is if I'm not
responsive. If AISTD is not responsive
to the turnaround plans and the risks
within them as a function of time
because you have one UA, 2A, 2 UA, 3U,
UA, four and five, then we as a school
district could inadvertently without
really understanding introduce risk that
would take local control away, right?
And it's happening right now in Fort
Worth and it happens relatively quickly.
So all of that is woven into this plan.
It's not a perfect plan. No plan is. Um,
but I want you to know that when we look
at different changes or um elements of
the plan, we're trying to address as
many of these things at the same time.
Uh, so I'm committed to listening. I'm
committing to refining. Um I will share
with you that when we started this
process like you know I I'm 100 I I felt
strongly that monastery needed to be
part of our academic program which is
why it's included but I also had to
address other things which I just
mentioned including accountability seats
etc with everything else around. So I'm
going to um I know we have lots I want
to create space for you all to have the
conversation with me and with the team.
Uh we have questions that we've received
from you all that we're happy to respond
to, but I don't want it to feel as
though this is not your time, right? So,
uh I'm happy to to make an adjustment
however you'd like, but I wanted to
share with you at least that um you can
make adjustments.
>> Before we get started, I just wanted to
um see if you could touch on one other
thing because it kind of came to our
attention. And I know some folks were
watching the board meeting on Wednesday
and there was conversation around the
compatibility of Monasuri um with the
STAR test and I just I know I shared
y'all I think someone created these
resources and we shared them with our
superintendent earlier today and I just
wanted you to touch on that a little so
folks kind of understand where you're at
with that.
>> Yeah. So I I would say from my
perspective where those um conversations
stem from it's this reality that the
state accountability system is is fairly
rigid. Um there are ways to approach
movement um that sometimes can be very
quick to achieve your goal. But there
are things that perhaps others do like
Austin ISD which are sustained long-term
like growth to where if I'm here or the
trustes are here, anybody's here, ASC
will continue to thrive. When it comes
to monastery, one of the critiques that
has been out that we need to be honest
about is the fact that, you know, when
you have um students kind of blended in
classrooms, it becomes harder to ensure
that the interventions are coming into
the space to to make sure that our
students are are getting getting what
they need to be successful on the
assessment. No one disagrees that
students are getting what they need at
WI. I want to be really really clear
like we believe and we see not only
through the data but also just who win
is the winning you know campus is that
outcomes are moving there's no doubt
it's just when you think about what what
fits and what doesn't fit easily into
the state's accountability system
monastery is one that doesn't fit easily
doesn't mean that we can't do it it
doesn't mean that it shouldn't be done
it just means that we have to be
hyperthoughtful be very responsive and
ensure that the research resources are
deployed to ensure success. That's
that's what I mean when we say that also
it's not lost on me that you know wind
monastery is one of 116 right in Austin
ISD in the state of Texas I can't
imagine it might be you know a hundred
out of like thousand I mean it's going
to be you know it's not something a
program that typically um is the focus
of those types of larger conversations
which put puts us at risk at times
whenever we're going through that work
with that lens.
>> Okay. Okay. And did you want to quickly
go through um just kind of what's
proposed and what has changed since
Friday?
>> Yes. In the draft plan um know that all
of you all are aware uh it contemplates
relocating um when uh monastery uh to go
valley again there was questions that
came out of the board and there was a
statement that was made in the cover
letter which I'm sure you all read which
means we're still continuing to explore
this specific um move. Why is this
>> I'm sorry y'all. I don't want y'all to
get
You want me to talk louder?
[clears throat] Talk loud.
>> Oh, the recording.
>> All right. So, we'll try that again. So,
what it means is that the students who
were zoned to win uh will now be
reszoned to Andrews Elementary School
and Hart Elementary School.
>> Could we maybe try turning down the mic
a little?
That would be that would be the coolest
thing ever if that was I mean
>> I have solutions
>> that sounds [laughter]
I thought it was my Apple pin. I have an
Apple pin which I somehow lost it seems
like. Um so we'll try to see how this
works. So um because win has a tap uh we
have to reassign the students um if
we're going to use that turnaround
strategy. Right? There are other
strategies that can be used. Uh there
are six of them in fact, but taps
typically are produced and implemented
at year two. So two UA once you get to
your third UA, which is where we are,
you have fewer and fewer options that
are truly viable. And when I say viable,
I mean to be accepted by the agency.
Doesn't mean that we couldn't do it. It
just means that the agency has built a
system that says the further you get
along in a process, the fewer options
you have. Um, which is why for us there
are reassignment,
restart, district restart,
right? Those are kind of the available
options given the number of ways that we
have
the microphone.
>> It's turn back on.
that speaker. It seems like it's almost
that speaker. It's coming through both
speakers.
While we're waiting, if you can turn and
introduce yourself to your neighbor and
tell them your favorite thing about win,
>> thank you so much for your patience and
thank you so much, but I know it's hard
to have technical issues in the middle
and such an important conversation. If
it happens again, I'll come up with a
new topic for you to talk about.
Take it away, Mr. President.
>> Uh, yeah. Um, so
>> amazing. Um, so, uh, we talked about
kind of the original draft of the plan,
right? And I want to be really clear
when we started this work, again, like I
said, supporting Monasuri and providing
the programming was important. We had to
break the accountability chain, which
meant we had to reassign the students.
We still wanted to make sure that all
students had access to the program that
were currently in the program, which is
why you saw us address transfers in the
way that we did in the revised plan. And
we were also trying to place the program
in a part of the city that would keep
another school from closing. Um, and the
reason I say that is because when we
look at areas of the city, we know that
in some areas we have lot of lots of
growth. In other areas you have lots of
decline in enrollment. And whenever you
can place a district-wide camp program
in an area that doesn't have enough
seats, it actually helps you keep a has
too many seats. I'm sorry. It actually
helps you not have to close an
additional school. So, those are the two
things when we were evaluating how this
could work. Uh why we we chose that
strategy at that time. Uh I will say,
you know, I've spent read lots of
Nadia's emails. I've read lots of other
emails.
Um and [applause]
and and so are there other options?
There there are things that can be
considered. The the one thing I want to
be really thoughtful around is anytime
you introduce a new option, you
introduce more like energy and
anxiousness and fear into the process
and the system. And so even at the work
session when we're being responsive to
trustees about exploring Ortega or
Zavala, even those conversations which
I'm committed to exploring requires me
and engaging with those communities to
make sure that we do it well, that we're
thoughtful and everybody understands why
it came about, right? Um and so uh
that's one of the things that I want you
to know is still underway right now.
We're still trying to find the solution
for this how this is going to work. I
can't I can't say that we're there. um
the conversations haven't completed um
but that is where we are in the process.
Now there were other um ideas that were
brought forward and so you'll have
questions around them uh and we can talk
about those as well and what that could
or couldn't look like given the time
that line that we're on. Um so just
wanted to make that point and then I
talked about transfers. I think it's
just really important to reinforce, you
know, our commitment to ensuring that if
you're a student who currently has
access to the program, you will be you
will have a seat available for you
wherever the program goes. Um, so I just
wanted to make sure that was clear.
>> I would like to go first whenever you're
ready.
>> You go. Go ahead. Go ahead. Let's go. I
mean, yeah, we don't need to I want to
make sure we It should be a dialogue. It
should be It should not It should be a
conversation like it shouldn't be us.
>> We'll go with you first. I love your
sweatshirt. Thank you so much.
Um the reason I want to go first is
because I I want to address something
that you just brought up that is kind of
how we are here. But you know I think a
lot of um this community wants to just
address maybe misconceptions or things
that we hear when we listen. Like we're
so much more engaged than anyone ever
thought you would need to be. Um and one
of those is
a just a big difference in the handling
of wallto walls. Um so the wall towald
language programs were moved to the
population that needs to be served
whereas when is being moved away from
the population that needs to be served
in order to solve a a district problem
and that led to you guys spending 45
minutes talking about monastery as an
instructional model and not never once
discussing these students with the
exception of the fact that they
shouldn't go into a new school and that
was I know not intended to be hurtful or
dismissive, but everyone who has a
student at this school, um, my
[clears throat] student is in his eighth
year at the school felt it immensely
because genuinely, not once were any of
these students discussed in that
discussion. And again, the wall to walls
are moving to their population. this
program is moving away from its
population which matters because if you
are going to introduce a bunch of new
students to to monastery part of what
makes it work is the students around
them who start working because they were
told to start working and don't need
that um small group instruction on
everything from the start which is why
we grew Monasuri one grade at a time
when we started
Um so moving this program away from its
population that makes it work right dol
works when you have 50% EBS and we're
moving towards those EBS monasteries
really similar and we are moving away
from the students in the plan as
discussed publicly thus far which is why
we're so focused on staying in northeast
Austin.
>> Yeah. So, um, no, great, great question
and this was a this was a point of
reflection for me after the board
meeting like because I I uh read the
emails um and I was reflecting about,
you know, how that conversation came
about and it's it's all it's it's it's
all my fault. I mean, it it it really
is. It's you know, my job is position
the trustees to have a thoughtful
conversation around any topic within the
the plan. and we kind of had the
conversation based on, you know, my
interpretation of what I received from
trustees. And so, we couldn't tackle
everything. I mean, we're we're pretty
pressed for time, y'all. Like, in these
meetings, it's pretty unfortunate, but I
I have like 20 minutes per topic, and we
went over like an hour and a half. So, I
want to apologize. I I never want any
family or any student to feel as though
they don't have a voice in Austin ISD.
That's not our intention. I'm sorry that
it came off that way. That's that's not
how I ever want to be. Um, so I'm sorry.
Um, regarding uh where the students are,
one of the things I would ask is when
you say that, is it defined by a
geographic region primarily or is it
defined by I have the map. I have the
map. I have the map, but it's
>> I have the map.
>> No, but it's where your current It's
where it's where your current students
live,
>> right? And so and so I just want to like
make a I want to be It's where the
current students live. I I've seen this
map. Yeah. I'm I y'all I read my emails,
y'all. Like I I spend time when I'm like
at 3 in the morning like sitting there
like that's what I'm doing. Um
so
when when we think about um student
populations and where they are, you
know, is it is it inconceivable that a a
monastery program could be successful
elsewhere in the city? I I just I just I
so so I think
>> need to be grown year by year.
>> I I don't disagree. I think that you any
program that we have just the way when
we started up general Marshall you start
six the next year is six and seven the
year after that sixth seventh and eth
how you have to be very thoughtful about
how you start a program but it's but it
it's not um it's based on how you start
it not always in this the student
population that resides in that area now
with emergent bilingual students like we
know where they live and we know where
the density of students are so I I would
say we we didn't apply the same strategy
for that reason. Um, and we always talk
about programs have moved and can move.
That's just the history of Austin ISD.
There are things that have grown like at
one point there wasn't a monastery here
and at some point there there was and
you know and that happens all throughout
Austin ISD.
>> So maybe because it we weren't we
approached it in that way we we took
that approach that led us to that down
that direction. Um, keeping it in this
area uh is not I mean I've read again
Nadia's emails. I think that there are
things that can be explored and we'd
have to be we'd also have to acknowledge
that there's we would run into the other
challenge that we have which is this the
seats. [snorts] So
so so I think that's that's something
that you know we're continuing to
explore. there's not a lot of like um I
always have to acknowledge that if
that's the case then this other
challenge that we have as a district
remember a district that I am trying to
address wouldn't get addressed in the
same way
>> right and and that's just the honest
truth but I I appreciate that comment
and that's why we built it out the way
question
I just want to make sure I understand
the question but I want to make sure
it doesn't follow up
So the question is, will schools in the
78723 area have a full day prek3 and
four? Which schools will accept students
who aren't eligible for tuition free?
Um, Miss Carden, can you address this
one?
Thank you so much. Um, so this is a
great question and we're working on this
and I'll share with you why. So the
prek3 is is interesting. Um, I can tell
you that we have a current list of preK3
uh campuses just for reference and Ally,
I'll make sure to share that with you to
see if we can add it to the October
31st. On the October 31st, we did
provide a list of all of the projected
preK4 campuses so that you could start
to see where those are offered. The
reason the preK3 is a little more
challenging to to answer is because we
have partners with our preK3 also. So
today I met with one of our partners and
we're agreeing that after November 20th,
if the vote is yes, then we will with
all of our prek3 partners get together,
right, to see which campuses. We want to
be very mindful about where our families
are, where the needs are, and our
partners as well. And just to give you
some background, our preK3 is half-day
program, but with our partners, it
allows for that full day program as
well. So that's coming. Please take a
look at the list of projected preK4
campuses which are on the October 31st
draft and we'll add the current campuses
to October 31st also so that you can see
where they currently are.
So clarifying question is the plan to
provide full day prek3
handbook
half day with teachers half day with
>> for the prek3 we we do need to look at
because of consolidation also right
there could be some programs at a school
that is proposed to to close or
consolidate. So we need to go back and
look at where our partners are going to
be where we have our prek3 half day and
then our prek3 with partners. So it's
not to to avoid answering the question.
It's there's a process for making sure
that we've got our prek3 programs where
they need to be and they start off as
half day and then with partners we're
able to offer the full day.
>> Thank you. And I'm come here to the this
person here for this next question.
Um, before I pose my question, sorry,
the corporate communications
professional, me,
>> can you talk as close to the microphone?
>> Yes, I can. I'm so sorry. Um, I just
wanted to clarify with her question that
basically
I want to make sure that I'm getting
this right. The gist of what it comes
down to is either we keep Monasuri in
this location and you're not starting
from scratch or you're moving the
location and you're starting from
scratch. Like that's the difference. So
what I when we talk about starting from
scratch,
>> you're not having model students. The
population is the students who have been
here, the model students.
>> So when we talk we built our plan out,
um the idea was to have staff go, to
have, you know, the program go, the
resources go. um you know and and one of
the things that we I talked to our
trustees about is to limit disruption
and and do the best we could to ensure a
healthy transition was to invite and
have as many [snorts] students go and
community go as well. So that's why it
ended up in this configuration opposed
to just a dismantling or like a split or
a north south like so so I I
>> do you understand what we're saying?
>> No, I understand what you're saying. If
you're moving the location, you're
starting from scratch because you're
going to lose a lot of the model
students like that.
>> So, I would say starting from scratch is
different would be if you did start if
you didn't have a monosur program in
your school district with the resources
with the work that we've done together
the last many years like which y'all did
the first time that was starting from
scratch. That that's the way I I just
want that's how I because we
>> okay I see it differently but I
understand what you're saying.
>> Yeah. I just wanted to clarify that.
Yeah.
>> Um I can
>> All right. I'm going to go with the next
comic card question. This came from
several people, but will families have
access, this kind of ties in, to
transportation for their students and
how far reaching will any transportation
be offered?
>> So, the the current mon so the monastery
program has transportation
um you know it's it's one of the things
that we are going to continue to have in
the plan um if it continues down this
this path. So as far as far reaching as
it is, I mean it's its current
configuration is is as wide as it needs
to be. We have families that access
transportation monator who live very far
away. Um we would expect that to
continue. That's how we ensure access.
Um so we're not anticipating a change um
in how we do that. Um so the current
access education wise would be um
preserved. And as far as how wide, well
depends on where the p student is that
wants to access the program.
And that's already I mean that's
>> so short answer there will be
districtwide transportation for anyone
who wants to do much sorting. Correct.
Correct.
>> Okay. We have a question here.
>> Hi my name is Jose Mustavante. I'm one
of the guides here. Uh dual language
fourth fifth grade. Uh you came into our
last year.
>> Yeah it was.
>> My biggest concern is not necessarily
where the school is moving. Uh and I can
understand I don't have children. Um my
biggest concern is resources for what
Monasuri is. So I started teaching at
Sims Elementary and that school was on
the verge of closing and we were asked
as teachers to come up with a plan and
we came up with a plan and the district
took us to Dallas and we saw Monasuri
schools and we said this is what we want
to do and the way that it was presented
to us was that you know we had the uh
autonomy to create a program and to
decide what direction we wanted to head
into but then it turned out that there
was going to be no support from the
district. So that's what I have my
understanding as what we're receiving as
resources.
I say all of that to to point out that
we now have a monatory program and it's
a very expensive program. It requires a
lot of more personnel and my concern is
that we're just going to move to another
building and we are going to continue to
have the um
the lack of resources of people. Just to
give you some context, and I'm sure you
know, last year I started out with
third, fourth, and fifth graders that we
were supposed to only keep for three
weeks and we kept for two months. And
that derailed my whole teaching, how I
could differentiate what I could do. Um,
the year before that, I inherited a
classroom because it was my first year
here that did not have a teacher all
year. So, these students had no growth,
no learning whatsoever. And then we were
in another situation last year where the
other uh ESL classes were in the same
boat. And so
I came to this school um because Bridget
asked me to. I was ready to quit
education. [laughter] I was ready to
quit education and move on to something
else. But I was really interested in
Monasuri. But my concern is that we're
just going to move into another building
that's just slightly more updated
[laughter] and that we're going to
continue to face the um
the challenges of giving our students
what they need when we don't have the
personnel, we don't have the resources,
we're sharing materials. So my concern
is that the district is not doing this
with fidelity. It needs to be done with
fidelity. Monastery is not easy. If it
was, we'd have more schools doing this,
right? So I understand that you're
having a hard time navigating equity and
equality because you know we want to
give schools everything that they need
but monastery programs need more they
and they do. Um and so how are you
planning on navigating so that we are
not just moving into another nicer
building but we don't have teachers.
This is the first year that I think all
of our classrooms are full and there's
been huge growth just in these last two
months in my opinion because we have
been more stable [applause] but we
didn't have that stability the last two
years that I've been here and it's
really disheartening to see Bridget
doing everything that she can to get us
where we need to be but to be continue
running into no it's not possible we
can't do that we can't do this we can't
do that. So it just seems to me like
again I use the word lip service because
that's how it felt when I was dealing
with this at SIMS where we are told to
come up with our best options, come up
with our best solutions and I understand
that you are being met with tea and all
that stuff. So I'm just wondering what
what are what are your uh plans to
provide us with what we need so that we
can be a successful monastery school and
so that we're not just a monastery
school by name. Sure.
>> I also just want to acknowledge you're
one of our TIA certified teachers,
right?
>> That means his scores were really good
for his kids last year. [cheering]
[applause]
>> Okay. My name is Sandy. I'm a lower
elementary guide here. This is year
seven for me. And my question matches up
with um the one of my colleague and that
is I've been here long enough to see
about half of the transition to the
monastery. So when Bridget came it was a
year where you had a special education
teacher who stayed a librarian who
stayed and a handful of primary staff
who stayed some teaching assistants that
stayed and then it was me in elementary.
So first, second, third, fourth, and
fifth. Everybody left. And so I've I've
been through that and Bridget has been
amazing with building up this team. So
I'm just looking at it from the point of
view of you're saying it sounds great
for students and for the building that
you're going to put our one half school
into a building and then offer one half
of the spots to new students.
And if you were going to have all of our
if all of our staff was going to move,
that would mean we would only have half
of the monastery staff that we would
need. If every single material that we
have in our building would move, we're
only going to have half of the materials
that we need. So my question is echoing
my colleagues in terms of it is
expensive to outfit a classroom. So
we're talking hundreds of thousands of
dollars to outfit part two the second
half because you're doubling our program
essentially by moving us to a larger
building and a larger campus. So my
question is I can understand the the
time that it might take to find the
monastery teachers and so that can grow
and I'm curious how that process would
happen but I'm also concerned that I
might find myself in a school um where I
can be in my own class and I can take
care of what's happening in my world but
not if I have don't have the materials
or if I'm having to share my one
classroom materials with three or four
classrooms.
>> Yeah. These are great questions. The
first thing I would say is um [cough]
from my initial response and and what
I've reflected on is you know when did
when monastery
right 22 23 you think about coming on
board you think about all the work y'all
that wasn't that long ago like I I know
I mean it really wasn't I mean y'all you
know Bridget you know we were learning
how to support them.
Sorry,
this feels weird. Um, like you know, we
we were learning. The school district
was learning. I mean, that's the honest
truth. I mean, I would say I'm not going
to speak for Bridget. Um, but our school
district was trying to figure it out and
understand how to support this program
and other programs as well. I would say
there are other programs in Austin ISD
that have not been supported in the way
that we should have supported them. And
what I go back to is okay well were we
prepared to launch the program or not. I
don't know I wasn't here at that point
in this role. Um I know that there was
you know lots of field trips. There's
lots of learning and understanding but
implementation execution is what it's
all about. And I think about where we
were in 22 23 23 24 25. You had lots of
superintendent lots of school leaders.
You had lots of people moving in and out
of the system. So I'm not surprised. In
fact, I think that y'all have moved the
needle in spite of lots of other kind of
external conditions that some of them
were in our control, some of them were
outside of our control. Um, now if we
move forward, you know, my objective is
to do fewer things better. Like right
now, we're an inch deep and a mile wide.
We got resources everywhere. All sorts
of different things happening in Austin
ISD. And our trustees will ask me like,
"Is it too much in some cases?" Right?
Are we doing things that maybe we
they're doing them because we've been
doing them, but if there are things that
we're going to commit to, you better bet
we're going to fund them. You better bet
we're going to allocate resources to
them. But we weren't set up like that. I
mean, in 20 22 23 when I came on board
and it was like a whirlwind. We're
dealing with the TA read special the
special education TA read order and that
kind of launched us in the next two
years. So what I would say is we've done
a lot of work around early literacy,
early numeracy, you know, building up
our climate and culture, making sure
that we have is in place to understand
where our students are. I want to
desperately get to a place where we can
focus on the important work not the
urgent work because the last three four
years has all been urgent urgent urgent
urgent and so um I would say that if we
move forward and this is a program that
we're supporting like you will have my
commitment to ensure that it's done with
fidelity and success. I've spent time,
you know, I'm not as well versed as I'm
sure many of y'all are, certainly not as
well as your principal, but my my role
is to ensure if we're going to do
something, we're going to do it well. In
order to do it well, we need to make
sure I have the resources to do it. It's
in our line item. It's in our budget,
and that our system is responsive. I'll
tell you right now that there are things
that we can do in Austin ISD to ensure
that we are responsive to unique
programs. uh we haven't always done them
um because sometimes they go against
what we've always done, but we can do
them.
>> So that's why I was I know that the term
reset I read an email that was offensive
and I understand why that feels that
way. But from operationally how we
support the program, we do have to reset
in Austin ISD. I need to figure out a
talent strategy or the the group that
hires isn't successful in supporting our
principal and in getting the hires or
whether it's certifications and how we
look at you know supporting our our
staff as they move through the process
then that's a change that we need to
make internally. It's not y'all it's us.
Um but I I'm not going to support
something that I know we can't execute
well and deliver well. The other thing I
would say is programs are more
expensive. You know immersion programs
are very expensive because we staff to
language right. So you can very quickly
get into a school that seems pretty
small and has a a cost per pupil, you
know, through the roof. And it's not
because you're spending more on a
principal or more on the facility. It's
because you made a decision that in this
school you're going to have these
programs and you're going to staff this
way. Emer programs are a good example of
that. When you look at the cost per
student, it's very very high. But it's
because we agreed that is what we're
going to do. Um, so, so that's what I
would say to that is if we do this, I
mean I [clears throat] told
we're going to do it well. I'm not gonna
I'm not going to participate in anything
that's kind of half I don't want to use
that word.
>> Matias, I can also add something because
I was just talking today to um Dr. J.
Brown who helps us with research and
evaluation. We're discussing releasing a
survey um once we have a vote um to
collect input from families about what
where they intend to go um what
information they need before they can
make a decision if there are certain
things that are important to them um so
that we can our goal is to have as much
clarity as possible when we open general
registration which is we're targeting
around midFebruary that general
registration would open is to have as
much information as possible for
families to know what will be offered at
different schools because it becomes a
bit of a chicken and thing where we
can't promise to offer a specific thing
if we don't know which students will be
there, right? But at the same time,
families can't make a decision if they
don't know what's being offered. So,
we're going to do this survey. Um, and I
have a woman right here and then I'll
get to you next. Um, that'll help us get
some more information about where
families want to be. And I think that
might add to or kind of respond to what
you were asking, which is if we can see
how many students we expect, then that
helps us understand how to staff and
resource it. Um, I'm going to go to this
comment card question because I think
it's a quick one, but because I want to
clarify something, but they asked, "Why
are you creating a new monastery school
that is unzoned and application based,
and I just want to clarify when we say
application based, um, families will
have to go into the system and indicate
they'd like to go, but it's not a it's
not like a merit-based application where
they have to have materials or things
like that. So, I just want to make sure
we use the word application because you
have to go and indicate your interest,
but it's not like an application like a
match or anything like that.
Thank you. Um [clears throat] I actually
spoke with you last Tuesday at the
Baptist church. Um thank you for coming
back to work here. Um the comment that I
made was specifically about busing and
kids in special ed who often have
private therapies after school. Um I'm
not going to repeat that question
because I don't want to waste anyone's
time. Um but the point that I made was
that you have private therapies or
anything. after school, busing is not an
equalizer for you because you still have
to drive to go get your kid. And then
>> sorry,
>> and I'm going to come back here because
it feels weird with my back to people.
Um,
busing does not work for children who
have afterare programs or for kids who
have private um therapies or other
things directly after school that
parents are required to pick their kids
up um to take them to. So, for three and
four year olds who do not qualify for um
going to city rec centers or uh Boys and
Girls Club or any of these other
programs, they will be they will stay at
the school that they're currently
attending until their parents are able
to pick them up. It doesn't cut down on
commuting for us. Um that's one point
that I want to make. Um when when you
were having your work session with the
board, there was discussion about
instead of going to Gabbali, going to
one of the other two schools, Ortega or
Zabala. Um the Ortega is about
equidistant and Zala is even farther
away um from this community that the
school is serving, which makes that
commute even harder, makes it less
accessible. Um, another point that I
want to make that I feel like several
people have been trying to bring up um,
before me is that
the educators and the students create a
symbiotic relationship and that is what
makes Monastery successful. So yes, we
are faced with three Fs. We're slated
for a C this year. We are so close to
making that and yes, I understand that
TEA does not care about that. that they
care about the threefs that we currently
have. If this program is moving to
another location, even with 100% of the
staff, there's a very good chance that
you're getting just a very small portion
of the kids from this school, from this
neighborhood going all the way to
another school. Mind you, a receiving
school that doesn't want us there. They
don't want us there. We don't want to go
there. I really think that we need to be
concentrating on northeast and then the
problems in East Austin, concentrate on
those problems there. There is a
geographic difference there. The
cultural difference is not dissimilar is
is not dissimilar. There are poor black,
brown, and special ed kids here too that
have not been served well.
I digress.
moving us to another location with just
a fraction of the students.
I'm concerned that that school that's
receiving a fraction of our kids is
still going to get another F because
we're not going to see the success that
we would with the symbiotic relationship
where we have the institutional
institutional knowledge, academic
knowledge between both parties. Um, the
other point that I want to make is that
Gov Valley, if we are still considering
Go Valley, has 39% of their student body
in special education.
My child who is in special education and
other people here with kids in special
ed, we understand how deeply resourceful
a school has to be in order to
accommodate those kids. I cannot in a
million years fathom where we are
already struggling with resources how
we're going to provide resources for 39%
of a student body to learn a complete
new pedagogy. I don't see how that's
even possible to be successful. Um
the last thing I'm going to say I don't
I I'm sorry I'm monopolizing time here.
have we talked to in either of our
neighboring schools to see if they would
consider what what the temperature is on
receiving monastery.
That way we'd be able to retain more of
our student body as well as more of our
staff. Have we talked to either of our
neighbors about whether or not they
would consider receiving monastery?
Thank you.
Um, no, thank you for sharing all a lot
of that and I agree with you on on
several fronts. Uh, regarding the the
speaking to um, you know, we're in this
moment now where if we need to have
conversations to to explore I I want to
be really honest with our trustees and
our community what that means and what
that looks like. Those who know me, um,
Nadia probably knows like I will I will
pivot. I will adjust. I will do what's
required to ensure that we have the best
plan considering the circumstances. Um
now my board the board of trustees asked
me to look at different things. Um
that's why Monasur is clearly called out
as one of these we're continuing to look
at. Um have I had direct conversations
um with those communities about this um
specific program group? Not in a like a
um formal fashion is the way that I
would say. Uh but we are now going
through and having conversations trying
to figure out if there's anything that
we missed before we got to this point.
And if there's, you know, support and
consensus, then we are happy I I am very
happy to progress the conversation um as
needed to to continue to address the
challenges we have, but also find a
solution that is a better fit. on the
other side, I have to just think through
if that's the place we end up the fact
that I'll still have a surplus of seats.
We'll set surplus of seats in that
community and that's a separate thing,
right? I mean, but I just want that that
is why we're doing it this way. Um,
again, I want to find the best solution
given circumstances. Uh, none of them
are going to be perfect. Um, but I will
convince and continue those
conversations and like that's why as a
statement on the draft delivery said,
we're continuing to look at this
specific plan.
I want to just add that you mentioned
you've mentioned maybe not these
students in a couple different ways when
we keep saying yes these students um I
do want to I want you to consider um if
like five years in the future this
monastery unzoneed school is working
because it had a balanced population of
monastery students but those monu
monatory students are all affluent
We don't have title one status any
longer. There are kids who were in
private monastery before. So they are
experienced monatory students and the
balance is working. Um but it's only
because we lost the the guard rails the
only way because I know growth is part
of why that why this is desired right
the new campus is larger growth from all
over the district. It's a it's it's in
the portfolio. It's part of the draw.
And also you want to hold on to the
enrollment guardrails. Um and so I I
want you to think about as you're you
know helping shape these decisions. If
in five years the reason it was
successful was because we had to remove
those guardrails in order to have
enrollment be it do the enrollment tool
you needed it to be and to do the seats
role you needed it to be. and it just no
longer has any of the guard rails that
this school has and that this community
is interested in. By the way, this
community would not be interested in
that school. Um, and I think that that's
a misunderstanding of this community
because some of us do have in affluence
and influence. The idea that you think
not
>> you said I think I
>> I know that's why I stopped. I stopped.
I think I think it has been thought
about this community particularly in the
conversation of not giving them a new
school, right? that that folks are
seeking um shiny things and and want
what is nice and new. And in reality of
this community, we have built a thing so
that it can work for this community
which is largely black and brown, highly
experiencing poverty, highly learning
English. Um and so I I did want to voice
that. Um, I understand Ally, I've been
coordinating with all these folks, so
this is something I've been asked to
share. Um, so I do want to I do want to
say that. So if you if you look back and
it turns out why it worked was because
you had to remove all of those
guardrails, removing them is part of why
you would lose this community as well.
>> I'm going to go to the person behind you
and then I think you were next.
>> Hi
Lopez. Um, so I want to touch I want to
go back to this community engagement
piece and keeping in mind and centering
the population that Nikki just described
in regards to who when Monastery is.
While this is a beautiful crowd of
people, this is not everybody that sends
their kids here. that this is a title
one school and the majority of the folks
here are unfortunately people that are
not able to be in this room and that's
what I'm very deeply concerned about
with the fact that they are not
[applause]
and from the parents that we do have the
opportunity to engage with particularly
Spanish speaking parents they have no
clue about what's happening and that is
alarming and so I wanted to hear about
specifically what the district is doing
to let those parents not only know about
what's happening but to have an actual
voice and meaningful engagement and
decision-m because this is their
children too. And I think that's very
heartbreaking why all of us we know we
have that privilege of being able to be
here at 4:00 on a Monday and there's a
lot of parents that are terrified not
only because of the fact that they can't
they're working they're you know to be
able to put food on their tables in this
terrible environment but they're
terrified of ice they're terrified of
not being able to be able to provide for
their families and being separated. But
not only that, but they don't even know
what's happening here. And it's not once
in a while. It's every family that we've
spoken to that is in Spanish that
doesn't even know that the school is
closing, doesn't know that they have an
opportunity. So, I'm just really
concerned about how they haven't been
reached out to. I've been working with
our parents uh support specialist and
he's been asking the district for
resources and they just tell him, "Play
back some of the videos and just explain
what's happening in Spanish." And that's
not the same as engaging with that
community. And I think that's a big huge
gaping hole and why there's some of that
distrust about is the district going to
be able to support us because we haven't
seen that even with just informing some
of these parents. And so I I would love
to be able to hear maybe there's
something I'm missing that you guys are
doing. But I'm just really concerned
about who's not in this room.
>> Yeah. So I'll have Ally kind of chime in
after I I start. So um I'm committed to
engagement. Like I I I have I will show
up. I will be present. Um, you know,
this is a large effort. There's a
there's a lot of things occurring
simultaneously in Austin ISD. That's
just the honest truth. We kind of lean
into, you know, what's available before
we come into a space. So, you know,
sometimes it's early in the morning,
sometimes it's late at night. We will
show up. So, I this I can't speak to why
4 p.m. and not 7 p.m. or why not
Saturday. I will tell you that we are
balancing many things and it's really
important that we get here and we're
present. In every instance, there's
always going to be someone who's not at
the table. And so, for us, we have to
figure out how do we get their voice
into the process, right? So, we have
obviously gone through the community uh
comment cards. Yes, we've had large
committee meetings. Yes, we voice even
like like you're sharing with me that
there's still missing voice at in this
area. Now, when it comes to decision-
making, I want to be like honest about
there are some things that are not going
to be possible. I mean, that's the
honest truth. I mean, it and it's not
because Matis doesn't want them to
happen. It's because the pressures that
we have in the system are gargantuan.
They're just huge. And if we don't
address them, then I'm not going to be
doing
you know what I should be doing for the
70,000 students. Like I have to think of
the whole, right? So I try to come down
understand live experience do the best I
can inform support and then go back and
forth. So I'm if there are other things
that we need to do to engage with this
specific community, please let us know.
We work with principal far. We so Alli
Alli right here is is Ally right here.
But I I just want you to know like we
are committed to engagement. We learn,
we adjust, we refine at any point, you
know, it it doesn't feel like that's
occurring. We need to know. But I also
don't want anything to be a reason why
we just don't take action. Like I I've
heard lots of times, well, what about
this? What about this? What about this?
And and I'm saying like we need to spend
time on planning implementation. Where
we fail is whenever we don't plan the
sequence of things that have to occur to
our students are successful starting in
26 27 school year. Like I've seen it and
I I'm not going to belabor this, but
I've seen it whenever we make changes in
the spring semester. Like we can engage
engage engage and then you know all of a
sudden be at the exact same place in
five months but we lost you know a lot
of time planning and it's going to hurt
our students. And so, um, I would prefer
that if there's something that really
requires us changing, like we talk about
what that means timelinewise, agree to
it, but not agree to just forget the
challenge that we as a district have to
to support and manage. But I'm Alli's
the person that you speak to.
>> Yeah. And I'm happy to connect with you
also, Mr. Garcia. So, we did something
that we did do is we looked at all of
the comment card responses and any
campuses that either didn't have
responses or had a low response rate, my
team met and came up with a plan for how
to do more outreach to those campuses.
So, we did more direct messaging through
text. We printed out flyers and
delivered them to the campuses so that
people could have QR codes. I know many
campuses their PTAs ca had different
events and so they actually had um like
iPads and laptops and helped people. We
told our PS's they could fill it out for
families. So, a lot of different
campuses done have done creative things
and we were able to reduce the number of
campuses. It I can say with confidence
the only campuses that had didn't don't
have responses as of this date are
campuses that have almost no changes
proposed. Every other campus we've
gotten that response rate up. But I'm
happy to work with Mr. Garcia, with you
and um we did have a fair number of um
Spanish speaking responses. My team had
to um translate it so that the the
subject matter experts could understand
the content. But we're happy to continue
working with y'all to make sure that we
get more responses there. Um, okay. So,
I know I called on Give me one second. I
called on you. There was a gentle I'm
sorry, you then you there's a gentleman
here and that's as much as I can
remember at once.
>> I have some of these other folks. So,
would you are you you are next? Would
you like to concede to
me?
>> Okay. Well, I'm gonna
these these folks also have. So, I'm
going to go here to this gentleman and
then back there. All right.
First and foremost, um I know many of
you may not agree with this, but I am
very thankful for Matias and I'm
thankful for our board. I'm thankful for
these hard things that they are doing.
Let's be honest, there there's not one
school district in Texas, probably in
the United States, is not going through
funding issues. Um, we've had these
issues for a while, but now we're we're
dealing with them. Um, and so I spoke
last week and some of the things that I
said probably were not very kind as I do
read everything that comes across from
AI to C. I get it from four schools. I
get it from where I work. Um, and then I
also just um read um to make sure I'm a
breast to all the information. Um, I was
like asleep the other night, woke up out
of my sleep as I've been doing because
this is very giving me a lot of anxiety.
Um, and so I woke up, I had an idea and
um, I don't um, I have a child that goes
here. He's pre-K3, but my plan was not
to have him continue here because I have
a daughter at Blandon. So he's three and
he's here all day. So he can go to
Bllandon next year all day. So he's
going to go there hopefully, cross your
fingers, that he can go there next year.
My idea is is that we have portables
here where Pon Springs is in. Um Miss
Bridget and um Miss Williams, they've
already worked together and they're, you
know, on different things, just you
know, managing the playground,
coordinating um um sharing things and
stuff like that.
Maybe it could work where maybe wind
moves into the portables and pan spring
moves into the school and then when p
when pan springs school is ready when
their school is finished building we
move all of us over to pan springs. The
reason why I thought of it is because
parents are saying we need to stay in
this community. We want to be here. Um
Pan Springs is not that far down the
street. Um it would be a lot closer than
any of the schools that you've proposed.
Um, I know that you're looking at, you
know, closing facilities. Um, I don't
know. That's just an idea that I had,
um, to maybe move in the portables and
have them move in here or have them move
in here with us and change the name or
whatever you need to do to maybe make
that work. Um, and then we would absorb
PCON spring students if they wanted to
be a part of the monastery program. That
that's just the idea I have.
>> Yeah. Now, and those are um, we can do
lots of things. Um, I will say that we
would complicate that is the fact that
win has three unacceptable
accountability ratings and so does pan
springs. And so really what helps us
break the accountability chain is
reassigning students to campuses and
then having that campus receive the tap
plan and then working with that campus
to break it. I'm not saying that there
aren't creative ways to to maybe pitch
something, but it would be more of a a
strategy pitch assuming the Pan Springs
community was engaged, involved,
supported, like all of this movement. Um
because one of the things I'll say is
because of how big the overall plan is
and what we're working through just
given our size, there are um different
like elements of the plan that we really
have to walk the agency through and show
them, hey, we're being very thoughtful
and intentional in ensuring that our
students get what they need to be
successful. If we can demonstrate that,
then you get, you know, the opportunity
to perhaps implement. But it would say
if if Pan Springs did not have the
accountability ratings that it did, that
would make that plan a lot easier to
implement. Um, but I'm happy to to
explore it. I know through the kind of
iteration after iteration iteration,
there are lots of different scenarios. I
know many of them. I don't know all of
them, but one of the things that I'm
doing as I dive deeper into this
specific um kind of challenge is to
become familiar and then be able to
respond each of these other ideas that
have come out because there are some
ideas that are coming out that you know
if it's something we can do I want to
explore it. I just be really clear to
our trustees this is what we're not
going to be able to do because we're
taking this path versus this path.
>> So is that helpful?
>> Yeah. The the kind of the assignment of
the students is what's required for
agency.
>> I'm gonna come back here and then over
there.
Hi, my name is LaGo. Um, I'm a parent.
We are zoned for when this is our
neighborhood school. Uh, six years ago,
ASC went through consolidation. We're
going through it again, as everybody
knows, and I classify this as a trend.
Um, our kid was in first grade. I'm
struggling to justify keeping keeping
him in a system where we can't even plan
for middle school at this rate. Um I've
asked and doesn't really seem that the
uh ISD has a strategic strategic plan
beyond consolidation. What is the ISD
doing now to prevent the next
consolidation in five to six years?
>> Yeah. So um I would say um you said
trend uh so I was here in 2019. Uh I I
saw that work. I oversaw much of the
work. Um, I would say I do not want to
be here. Like, this is the most painful
place I've ever been in professionally
and probably even personally. Uh, this
is horrible. Um, I hate that our
community is going through it. I'm hate
that I have to be the person to to lead
us through it. This is I don't want this
for anybody. Um, I I desperately want to
get to a place where we are thriving,
growing, like it's sustainable. Like I
said before, we've been tackling urgent,
urgent, urgent, urgent. Um, when 2019
occurred, Shortly thereafter, the
pandemic happened and then all bets were
off. We had mass exodus of staff. We
began to rebuild. We had leadership
changes. We didn't have systems in
place. And so the last two and a half
years, we've been working. I mean,
you're not only working here at WIN,
like we are moving early literacy
outcomes. We're moving early numeracy
outcomes. I mean, we're there are
presentations that we've been giving
over the last many months that show like
our system, our system is responding and
it's happening our way. So I it can't be
a trend, but I also don't want to say
it'll never happen again because I don't
know what could or couldn't happen at
the federal level, what could or
couldn't happen at the state level. I
will tell you right now, there was a
conversation that comment over here
about ICE like immigration is hammering
us right now. I have so many immigrant
families that chose to to not come to
Austin ISD or chosen to leave. So that's
an over 2,000.
That's millions and millions of dollars
that that that
those students represent. But what's
most disheartening is that those
students in some cases are still here.
They're just choosing not to come to
school because of the fear that's in the
system. And that is like what's most
disheartening about all of this. So um I
want to get to a place where there is
more understanding and a thoughtful
approach to what we're doing
academically, what we're doing when it
comes to our strategy around um being
inefficient when it comes to staffing.
so that you as a parent, anybody as a
parent in Austin ICD understands what
they're going to get out of us as their
student moves through our system. And I
tell you at the end of the day, what we
keep coming back to is our values. Like
we we've agreed on certain things. If if
that's not who you our community is,
then we will change. But I have not
understood that. I I desperately believe
I mean I say I believe that you know our
approach is sound. Um I wish we had more
time. the 23, 24, and 25 accountability
coming out within five months of one
another that really put us in a
difficult spot. So, no, it's it's not a
trend. I hope it's not a trend moving
forward, but I can tell you if we only
do a piece of this plan or if we only
tackle a quarter of it or half of it, we
will be here. There's no doubt. Um,
we'll be here again because my argument
and is that if we have the resources to
ensure every student gets what they
need, then those students um those
schools that have historically maybe not
accountability will they'll have the
resources, you know, and that will draw
families in. Lots of families are making
decisions based on very limited
information. They they y'all know how
awesome one is, but there are families
that may move in and just see the the
ratings and they're going to make a
different decision and that happens all
throughout Austin. So, um, so that's our
approach. We're moving forward. I don't
want it to be a reoccurrence. In fact, I
don't know.
I mean, that's just the honest truth.
Matias, I'm going to just add to that
because I think one of the challenges
when you have so many underenrolled
schools is that for example, I'm in the
communications department and families
have asked us when we were at Marshall
like what what does every single Austin
IC middle school offer, right? And it is
hard to answer that question right now
because you might we might have
standards that we say we want every
middle school to offer, but if they have
a small student body, it's hard for that
class to make, right? And it's hard to
fund a staff for a very small class when
you have the budget constraints that we
have, right? And so I think one thing
that we as we move forward with our
academic planning is that we can
actually get to a place where we can
define what needs to be offered that
there's actually a robust enough student
body at each of our schools to be able
to offer it and then the funds to
actually make it happen. And so that I'm
I know I'm personally looking forward to
that because it would be much easier on
us if we could say I can promise you
that no matter what these are the things
that are offered at an elementary level,
these are the things that are offered at
middle and these are the things that are
offered at high and then there might be
extras, right? But this is that baseline
and that's something that we have
struggled to do and this process will
help us do and I think with that ability
to communicate it more clearly that's
going to I think help recapture families
that maybe have decided they're not
going to want to stick with Austin ID
temporarily hopefully.
Hi, my name is Camille Sailor. I've
attended
Austin Independent School District
Elementary, Middle School, and High
School. I now have a daughter at Win
Monasuri.
I taught high school AIDS for about 10
or 11 years.
Um, this [snorts] is my fourth year at
WIN. Um, I myself been a product of
Austin Independent School District
special education.
At a time when there was a lot of change
in special education,
some of it at AIC my mother fought for.
I said I would never be a teacher
because of the way it made me feel.
Here I am now working with kids so they
don't have the same experience. Hi,
[applause]
my question is
if AISD believes in having a monastery
wherever it is,
you need to have someone at the district
level with monastery experience in a
monastery background in being a leader
in a monastery school, not a Texas
public education school because that's
not what we are. We are monorans first
and foremost. We need someone at the
district level to fight for us. We also
need a principal
who knows what they're doing. We have
one and it's her choice if she wants to
go. But if she doesn't, we can't just
have some principal from another public
school. It's not going to work. It's
going to fail again. [applause]
And it's
starting all over wherever we are. So my
question is when it comes to you all
selecting principles for new campuses,
what can we do in maybe helping
influence you all to consider someone
whose monastery experience in leadership
at the campus level and also at the
district level.
>> So um so you're an AIC graduate. Did I
hear that? Do you mind if I ask where
you went to high school at?
>> Macllum.
>> Macllum. Where'd you go to middle school
at?
>> Lamar.
>> Lamar. Awesome. Elementary. Sorry.
>> Hi, Lamar.
>> All right. I'm going to give you
something before you leave. You don't
have to remind me.
>> Um, so, uh,
one of the So, the I'm going to speak
specifically the principle. Um, so what
to do to to communicate to me? Um,
you're doing that. I I I tr trust me I
am not lost that the leader of this
school a leader of a future school has
to have all the knowledge the
understanding of a true monastery model
have experience being successful in it
um and that doesn't come out of someone
who just is transitioning from another
elementary school I I recognize that uh
I think you know Bridget's done a
tremendous job in very difficult spot uh
there's no doubt but as we move forward
forward. It's really important that I
identify these leaders sooner than
later. And here's the reason. Uh we put
a milestone out there in early December
and that's really an effort to ensure
that staff who we love and care for and
we want to stay in Austin ISD stay in
Austin ISD. Right. And so once you hire
the principal and there's agreement and
understanding of why this person is the
right leader, they then can move to hire
staff. And that way our families have a
have a clear understanding of what to
expect before you too far along into the
registration process. Which is why time
matters. If I wait till December or
January, then we're into the spring
semester. Hiring becomes a completely
challenging place for us to be. Um so
that's the approach that we're going to
take. Um if there are more things that
you'd like to send me, um please send
them to me. A copy Lisha drinks um our
chief of staff. uh if you think there
are different uh skill sets or
requirements that you want to have us
consider um please please please send
those along. I do not do anything
without spending a tremendous amount of
time trying to understand what the best
fit is. And the rare instance that we
don't find that person and we we have
the ability to slow things down just a
tad. But I want to make sure that
everybody understands the reason we set
this timeline is I want to protect
staff. I want to make sure our staff
know who is going to be leading these
schools and then we make those decisions
early and if a staff doesn't want to be
at that school or wants a different
experience in Austin ISTD, we offer that
and all of that completes before we
offer a single position outside the
district. Um so so thank you for sharing
that. Um I can certainly reach out um if
you shoot me an email and talk to Lisha,
we can also take it that way. But that's
a big part of this work. Okay, we are
actually already at time, but I know
that we had some technical difficulties
and got started a tiny bit late. So, I
saw three hands that I'm going to call
on. Miss Bradley, Nadia, and then you'll
be our last question.
>> Actually, I've heard so much and I'm not
even sure if I really have anything much
to say, but I do have maybe two or three
questions and I'll do it as quickly as I
possibly can.
>> [laughter]
>> It could have been five or six.
>> Some of you know me well. [laughter]
>> Actually, you had stated 45 students at
least you had told me uh maybe a couple
of weeks ago or so that 45 students here
would transfer to heart
>> that were in the attendance boundary
assigned. So
>> not transfer they they would get to
transfer wherever they would like. Well,
they'll be zoned to correct park. And so
where is that 40? Where are those 45
students located?
>> It's that weird little island that for
whatever reason.
>> We have the boundary on the map. We can
probably
>> Okay. So, I thought you were speaking of
another another location.
>> Okay.
>> So, you can see it. I guess that one's
not moving. But behind you, Miss
Bradley, you can see it.
>> Oh, no. I'm good. We [laughter] can move
on.
We can move on.
>> It's that yellow.
>> I'm good. Brilliant.
>> Uh the other thing is
I'm not sure is being captured of what
is really important here.
This community
actually lobbyed for the Monasuri Bury.
So did Sims. It was going on at the same
time. So Bamanti was correct. We went to
Dallas. We looked at uh Christine Moss
Elementary which was a Monasuri school.
Somehow went ended up getting the
Montasauri program. I have a
granddaughter here. She's in the third
grade.
One of my biggest I I guess uh I guess
my question is kids may may go to other
schools. and may transfer to other
schools after being here for years in
the monastery program. How are they how
is the district going to help them adapt
to a traditional program? The other
thing is more of a comment. I don't want
to see another survey.
[laughter] I mean, no, I'm serious. How
many surveys can you give?
>> Well, that's to go to staff. Not we're
not Miss Bradley, you hopefully. Are you
employed by us this morning?
I was employed by you [laughter] and
what mean and wouldn't be survey there's
a survey for everything and you think
everyone is going to fill those out.
There are some people that are just not
because in some case they may not have
the skill set too but they know what to
say. So these type of engagements are
important.
>> I agree.
>> But then my other question is I haven't
seen an academic plan. So how would you
support those students that have been in
this program um since third, fourth and
fifth? And how are you going to uh
ensure that they have that they are they
can adapt to a traditional program? the
uh Oh, I said I had three questions,
right?
>> I think you're on five. [laughter]
>> One more. Uh the other thing at a board
meeting, you said the board did not want
you to go under 15% with the fund
reserve.
>> What are you all sitting at
[clears throat] right now?
>> Um what are we at? Where's the where is
Katrina at? I think we we ended up um at
the end of the school year um at closer
to 17%. Um and so because we were
cutting cutting cutting at the end of
the year and that contributed to the
fund balance. Um but also Miss Bradley
and you all probably were tuning in um
we're actually having to extend a line
of credit in order to cover cash because
fund balance is in from beginning of the
fiscal year to end of fiscal year if you
sum all the you know all of it together
the revenue and the expenses then you
end up that total amount. But over the
course of a year, you know, we have hu
huge expenditures at the beginning of
the school year and our fund balance
draws down down down down and then right
around this time in November, we begin
getting funds from the uh the county um
uh property tax. Yeah. And so it comes
in in November. Now, what's happening
this year, so I don't want to alarm
anybody, but we are going to be
extremely tight on cash and we're
looking to go like negative to where I
need to line of credit. the state um uh
law, the one that's being voted on,
right, around homestead exemptions, that
has caused all the property uh the pre
the appraisal districts throughout the
state of Texas to delay how they go
through the process of sometimes
releasing their bills or how they're
going to get funds coming in. So, those
are our dollars. So, now they're coming
in slower. So, the exposure in the month
of November is longer. So, we got to
17%, but even with 17% at the end, we're
still going to actually have to borrow
for about six days um in the second week
of November because of that nuance
around money coming in late. Um so, so
that's where we are. Um and it's just
the reality of how cash plays into all
of this. Our payroll per month is about
$53 million. Um and then the total
outlay, meaning like other expenses, is
closer to 57. So, it's a big system and
and that cash that balance allows us to
make sure that every single person gets
paid. The one thing that can never
happen, disruption of pay ever. Now, I
will not let that happen. Um, you had a
question.
>> The question about students that are
going from monitor to
>> Yeah. So, that's a really great
question. We haven't talked [snorts]
about this and gla standing next to you
or sitting next to you. Um, we are
creating um bridge teams. Uh, these are
teams that are coming together that
include both school communities to
understand each student and each
student's experience through this
process. uh some of it will be at the
school level like PTA, CAC program, but
it's going to go student by student and
say okay this student has these needs
you know what is how are we going to
support him or her um through this
process um so it'll be reflected in the
the bridge teams um that'll be campus to
campus based on transition so you're
going to have you know see that uh and
then I am going to hold everybody
accountable accountable by tracking key
performance indicators and milestones to
deliver on that plan uh So, so that's
how it's going to work for each student
in this experience.
>> Theoretical. Well, so I can't create a
plan. Let's have community involved. So,
I can't tell you the the I mean, this
plan is changing.
>> I I I do the work, Miss Bradley. You
know, I mean, I I I I
will I I work I deliver as best I can.
I'm not going to put anything out there
that I don't think we can execute and do
well. Um, but to your point, I can't do
something without community voice input.
I mean if if this plan changes
>> I believe in the engagement. I guess
what I'm saying is that this district
has uh this district has a a tendency of
coming up with these theories that they
feel would work and then they will try
to put it.
they will try to implement it and then
the next thing you know they're standing
there maybe for the first month and then
the next thing you need they know you
know they have left and so the school is
trying to implement something that the
district put in place. Uh the other
thing is there are several schools
around here
>> that are open. This program could go
into one of those. It's a community
program and that's what we should be
looking at and uh for some odd reason we
can put things into Artega to keep it
open. We can put things into go valley
to keep it open but we need to think of
these schools the same way we think of
Artega and Go Valley.
>> And I just want you
>> Miss Montgomery our CFO was here and I
had to go because there's an ad hoc
meeting but the budget ended at 18.6%
6%. Yeah.
>> Yes. Yes. Is it related to this?
>> Okay. Please do. Yes. Translation does
not mean understanding.
I think that
See,
>> I I I wanted to do it in Spanish because
it's it's my home language, but
translation does not mean understanding,
right? So the fact that you think that
just translating that will mean people
will engage is disingenuous and it is
also disrespectful, right? Um it takes a
lot of time even for somebody as me
which is highly educated to understand
what is going on, right? Like I have to
read three times Nikki or Nadia signals
to be able to understand what is going
on, right? So, and by that I mean it's
is disruptive, right? And that leads me
to the fact that look, you had a program
who has taken a lot of effort from
parents, from the community, from the
staff. This staff is amazing, right?
They have great stuff, right? [applause]
You had a problem of failing schools.
You don't have that here. You had
enough, but you had a school who is
growing. You had a school that is
engaged. you had a school that's Montes
or is a dual program that is serving a
diverse community. Why would you want to
disrupt that, right? I mean, how is that
going to serve your actual long-term
goal of having a schools that do not
fail, having a schools that T is not
going to come on your neck and just like
really um serving equity and and and and
the and the students population and the
community, right? Like I don't I don't
like from everything you have said like
I agree with her like I agree I
understand that you guys are under a lot
of pressure right this administration
sucks. I get it but it is like why are
we doing things right that is actually
disrupting something that is good.
>> So um thank you for that. I want to
respond um briefly because I there were
I really appreciate these comments. Um,
we could always do better engaging. I
mean, that's just the honest truth. We
we we try there's always an opportunity
for improvement. Um, you know, and what
we learn helps inform where we
ultimately get. Uh, I also want to be
really clear that there are lots of
other schools um that are in similar
situations. Um, there are eight other
schools that have 59s. There are three
others that have 58s, two that have 57s,
and they have se seen significant
growth. I mean there is 45 55 59 and
those schools are incredible too and
they're doing incredible things and so I
just I know that um we're talking about
wind monastery but I I just want you all
to know that there are lots of other
really awesome things happening with
schools that have very similar kind of
histories and somewhat similar
trajectories. Um because I I just wanted
I wanted to share that because I it it
is hard. It is really really hard. we
have 116 schools um to to get it right
and I I don't know that we are but we're
trying
>> can hear me. Um so I think that I was
hoping that we were going to come here
today and then you guys were going to
have vetted all these ideas that we gave
you but since that isn't where we're at
right now I'm just going to lift those
ideas and I think it spins off of what
you were saying. I think that we know
there's a lot of schools around us that
are struggling and I think when we look
through stuff we say hey everyone's
struggling here's and for a very
different reason for each school maybe
this school wants to team up with us for
this reason and so none of these are we
saying like we need to take over those
schools I think nobody feels that way
and I think but yet we put forward this
idea in a constructive way of maybe
there could be a collaboration
um and I'm not going to go through the
reasons why we picked these for each one
but it happens to all the schools that
are around us. Um, and that is because
we're also looking for something that
was local. Um, it included elementary
schools Andrews, Pan Springs, and
Jordan, as well as Pickle and the Sims
Elementary campus, which is currently
empty, and the Bertha Saler means and
Gus Garcia campuses, which have empty
space. So, I wanted to just put those
out in the record. Um and then I did
want to ask a question about um our
surrounding schools also have are
experiencing unacceptable ratings one,
two, and three. And um right now our our
TAP is currently slated to go to
Andrews. And so maybe that'll stay the
same, maybe that'll change, but
whichever school gets our TAP, um they
also inherit our timeline if I
understood. So my question is if Andrews
if if Win were to get a fourth F this
year, which of course everyone hopes
that we all get C's. Um and if Andrews
was to get a fourth F, Pan Springs was
to get a fourth F next year. Is there a
contingency plan that goes along with
all of our elementary school taps that
includes closure or 1882 partnership
like is planned for the middle schools?
>> Yeah. So, this is something that's come
up with our with in conversations with
our trustees. So, for those of you that
um don't don't know, um what an 1882
partnership affords a school district is
a two-year pause. So typically what
would happen is um if we didn't have all
these years back to back to back you
would get your first unacceptable rating
your second unacceptable rating you
would draft your plan right and then you
would implement your plan in year three
and then four and five to break
accountability chain and get a seed
that's how it's supposed to work because
of everything and the lawsuits which we
were not a part of but because of all
that everything's been compressed and so
um one of the things that we are
proposing for Doby burn it in web is
that as we monitor this school year if
we don't see growth or if we don't we
have a concern that they're not going to
get a D or better because D pauses right
D is good D is a movement in the right
direction of pauses um then we can
actually make a decision and execute an
agreement with an 1882 partner and that
would allow for this year the year that
we're currently in to be considered one
of the two-year pauses right so it would
mean that the fourth year would not
count against us the only caveat This is
where it gets really really tough is you
have to make the decision before they
actually take the star tests, right? The
they have they call it the Dallas rule.
Years ago, there was a closure that
occurred after they said if what they
did is before the school year started,
they said if the school makes an F,
we'll close it. It makes a C, we'll
leave it open. And so that was kind of
like a loophole that's since been closed
up. And so the way that they we have to
address it is whatever we decide to do,
it has to be done before the students
take the start test. Um so in the late
spring, right? Um so Could these plans
include that contingency? Yes. In fact,
our trustees have expressed to me, not
in the large room, but one-on-one, that
they would like to see that type of
contingency plan included in these. Um,
but I also know how most of our
community responds to 182 partnerships.
Um, because in the the way the agency
accepts them is has the partner
demonstrated the ability to turn around
school. Um, and there aren't lots of
partners out there that have. You have
lots of partners that do all kinds of
great things. um but they're looking for
very specific elements uh or skill sets.
So yes um closure um it would be it
would look different closure because
closure wouldn't necessarily give you a
pause. You'd have to close before they
actually took the test. Um I'm not sure
how that would work. You'd have to it
would look a little bit different but
1882 would be one.
So this just increases the importance I
think of talking to our neighborhood
schools about what our vision is of our
elementary schools in the neighborhood
because I think in one to two years if
we have any of our schools looking at
closure and then this program that we
had that was quite successful and has
been released from its tab like like I
feel like there are many opportunities
for collaboration that could help keep a
neighborhood school open and someone
else may also like the idea of going on
that pathway with us as opposed to
>> and I'm happy to um you know I I know it
seems like a long time the board meeting
was last Thursday um Wednesday Thursday
and then we moved into pretty and
challenging weekend um just honestly and
so we're we're coming back together
we're doing the work we're progressing
the work um this week where there's lots
of meetings occurring so I can speak to
some of the because I read your list and
there are some thoughts I have around
why some may could be considered and why
some couldn't. Um specifically the last
two that you um solution schools that
you listed the last two groups of
schools. Um but yeah, I mean we're happy
to have this conversation. If there's a
school that's nearby um that wants to
engage in that conversation, um I'd be
happy to have it and explore it together
as a school community. What I don't want
to have happen is is the counterposition
which is well now you're just displacing
us right which is gonna that's gonna I
understand why that would be the case.
Um the last thing I would say is if you
were to go to go valley breaking the
accountability chain means that um win
would be able to continue without the
the weight of the previous
accountability ratings. You go to a
school that has a two or three they're
then going to assume theirs potentially.
Right. So like so
Yeah, it it that's where we have to kind
of get into the the details of how the
sequence would work. Um, you know,
closure, reassign, uh, certainly can
work. Um, but depending on where the
school started elsewhere, that receiving
school would have to be a closure,
reassign, and then a new. So, so that's
what you're saying?
>> Yeah. I mean, potentially, I mean, I'm
happy to have those conversations. Like
I said, if you find a solution that
works and our trustees can get behind
it, um, and there's an alignment, then
then I want to progress it. I I I you
have that commitment for me. I know
we're kind of getting
>> Yeah.
Well, well, so here here's the thing is
um so
>> what what what what I've told the
communities is if the ideas come my way
I will vet and test them to see if if we
can actually accomplish them like some
of them we can some of them we can't if
they if they are viable then the
conversation occurs
>> correct and then and then if they are
then the conversation becomes okay let's
get a couple people in the room some
stakeholders some members we're not
talking about getting like 300 00 people
together and just hashing it out. We're
talking about getting some key members
of the community who know the school and
have a good understanding of what may be
accepted and what may not be accepted.
Uh and it has to be done in short order,
but we can do it. And and here's the
thing, like I want to find the best
solution. I I I really do. Um and I I
will do the work, but to your point,
ma'am, um I think getting a conversation
together, I'm not sure that I can be
there, but Lisha, our chief of staff,
our others to help facilitate and bring
people together to drive it. like we can
do that. Um, and I'm also doing this at
other schools, right? For for for
different reasons, right, that came out
of the board meeting and also based on
conversations.
>> Okay. So, as you can hear, the child
care is getting a little bit restless
and we have teachers that are graciously
get them home.
>> Yes. And so, this will be our last
question and she's gonna
>> Okay. No, I'll be very very quick. I'm
probably going to piggy back on what has
been said. I want to also personally
thank you for being here, for having
this kind of a conversation. has been
very very helpful and I appreciate all
the comments that we've been able to
hear so far. I want to say that I agree
and I believe we agree that the district
can't afford to lose students or have a
district takeover and we really want to
work together to kind of help solve the
problem. You've heard a lot of ideas, a
lot of thoughts. Uh we've also talked
about why we believe the guys see these
long story here that we're actually as a
program in dollars to the district by
our enrollment by our
Uh question to piggyback off this is is
there any reason that the Montasuri
program couldn't be located temporarily
at a swing space such as Sims while we
are working through the town and
considering that there might be more
changes as they mentioned next year if
other schools such as Andrews or county
springs possibly gets another restart.
Maybe there's a more permanent
multi-story home or another set of
choices that could come about because of
other factors.
>> Yeah. Um so quick response. Um the
reason a swing space probably won't work
is because there's not a current there's
not currently a school there. And so if
there's not a school there, I have to go
to the commissioner Texas agency and ask
for them to allocate a CDN number. Uh
the CDN number is what gets attached to
your accountability rating. And I will
tell you that in my experience in
working with the agency, they're not
going to allow you to start a school
unless you have a thoughtful plan, you
understand how you're going to staff it.
You know, everything has built up and
they also know what we're working
through with right now. Uh so we we do
have open dialogue with them to make
sure that we're not kind of getting over
our skis on any one of these things. But
that's why a swing space probably
wouldn't work in that way. the better
strategy to to move is to go to a school
that already has a CDN because you can
always change programs in a school but
you can't just create new schools. Is
that helpful?
>> Um but yeah, no that uh no I appreciate
that question. It's it's a very good one
to ask and clarity. But I am committed
to looking into working with other
schools to see what and if y'all are
having conversations and you know that
there's a school that's open to having a
conversation, you let us know, too.
>> Yeah. Northeast has started to have
community conversations and we're trying
to a lot more collaboration because it
feels like um we are just more
knowledgeable about our community.
That's always going to be true for a
variety of reasons including a lot of
our leadership is not from this area of
town. Um and so as those happen because
they keep happening um we'll share out
what we what we
>> Well, I mean yeah I need I mean I need
to have these conversations later.
>> Yeah. No, like
>> as soon as
Thursday.
[laughter]
>> Okay. And while we're talking about
timelines, just wanted to do a quick
reminder of everyone. Um, so we have a
board meeting this Thursday where the
board will discuss this revised plan.
Um, the final recommendation will be
going to the board at their November
20th uh board meeting. Um, and that's
the the no the Thursday before fall
break. So, we'll be in touch. Y'all know
how to get a hold of us. Thank you so
much for all of your wonderful comments,
ideas. We really appreciate y'all.
>> Thank you all for being here. Thank you
so much for joining us today.